hello YouTube I believe you a pew of the
CEO of gemalto here in Davos actually I
began in the state of the economy a much
more bullish and many of the doom and
gloom he around I believe that all the
doom and gloom is led mostly by a happy
fuse and in fact the economy which is
you know all the full of us working in
the field whether we are in the common
areas or urban areas whether we are in
large countries we have not said much
touched by the explosion of hedge funds
or so so yes there is a tough time to
come in but we should not fall into the
fear of the crisis it will it has but
it's you know we have recovered of many
others and I see if it really intense
mature